a lichen actually consists of two
organisms a fungus and algae or
cyanobacteria
or so we thought for a hundred and forty
years in lichen the fungus provides a
home while the algae provides nutrients
together they form the unusual
structures that grow on the surfaces of
rocks and trees lichens break down the
rocks into soil take up pollutants from
the air and live in places most other
organisms boy it's hard to do genetics
in lichen they grow slowly by themselves
tightly to their substrates and when
they are sequenced they yield a mishmash
of DNA from two organisms take these two
related lichens there are different
colors and one makes a toxin looking at
both the fungus and the algae gene
activity in the two lichens researchers
saw no differences but when they look to
the activity of all the genes they
discovered a yeast was also part of
these lichens so the twosome was
actually a threesome these yeast genes
were more active in one of the lichens
possibly explaining the difference in
color to prove the yeast were really
there
the researchers labeled each of the
lichens organisms with florescent acts
they discovered that the yeast coat the
outer wall of the fungal hairs and are
surrounded by toxic acidic crystals the
algae lined the inside of the wall they
found the yeast in many other lichen on
different continents suggesting that
this is a widespread three-way
partnership gone undiscovered for over a
hundred and forty years